No one wants to be bullied.
Everyone wants to feel like they mean something to somebody.
It's definitely a hard four years of your life, you know.
Even a few words can affect someone so negatively.
Opening a door is more than a physical act.
It's like putting yourself out there,...
...getting to know people, make them feel comfortable,...
...make them feel welcome.
Opening doors, it gives people hope that people care.
I  personally think that you shouldn't let what's going on around you...
...affect your personality or the way you act.
Be courageous.
Don't let the bullies get you down.
Just fight back in your own way...
...maybe with a little kindness.